many of you have been holding off on
buying the budget $329 iPad because of
rumors of new 2019 iPads coming soon and
now they're finally here the 2019 iPad
Mini 5 for $400 in 2019 iPad air for
$500 the new mini may not be that bad of
a deal but the new air is extremely
underwhelming and anyone looking for a
new budget iPad should not buy it I
repeat do not buy the 2019 iPad air I'll
give you all my personal recommendation
on what to buy in just a minute
ultimately it's a handicapped version of
the 2017 10.5 inch iPad pro it's using
the same chassis display resolution
battery Apple pencil support and more
but although it seems like it's just as
good it's missing some very important
components of the pro so here are five
things that are lacking compared to the
10 point five inch iPad pro the first
two have to do with the display first of
all the display brightness is limited to
500 nits instead of the pro 600 nits so
it's quite a bit dimmer and it doesn't
support HDR video even though it
supports P 3 wide color gamut secondly
it doesn't support pro motion which is
the one thing that made the iPad pro so
great it basically doubles the screens
refresh rate to 120 Hertz so every swipe
in animation is buttery smooth trust me
this makes a massive difference in
day-to-day use not only that but
promotion also significantly reduces
Apple pencil input lag making it seem
like you're drawing on actual paper the
new air really misses out by lacking
promotion now the third thing isn't that
big of a deal for an iPad but it still
sucks the rear camera is only 8
megapixels compared to 12 on the iPad
pro so you don't get 4k video recording
or 1080p at 60 and picture quality goes
down as well for the fourth thing the
new iPad air only has one set of
speakers on the bottom compared to 4
speakers on the 10 point 5-inch pro the
speakers were both louder in the stereo
sound and landscape mode was amazing
compared to the old 2 speaker setup all
in all the new air is just lacking way
too much for me to be able to recommend
it yes it's got an 8 12 processor that's
more powerful than the a 10x
but to be completely honest it was
already tough to notice the difference
between the a 10x and the a 12x
and the new iPad pro at least in
day-to-day use the a 10x and the 10
point five inch pro can run basically
any app or game currently available on
the market so the a12 doesn't really
make that big of a difference now you
might be saying of course that pro is
better that's why it's called a pro well
in reality Apple was selling the pro for
$650 only $150 in the new air and it was
definitely more worth it just for the
promotion technology alone unfortunately
Apple took the pro off their website
this morning as soon as the new air was
available and we all know why now here's
the good news you can easily find a use
10.5 inch iPad pro for under $500 or
refurbish models on Amazon with prime
shipping for only 434 dollars you can
even get a brand new one on sale for
only five hundred seventy dollars on
Amazon with prime shipping if you're
thinking of getting the new air don't
buy a used ten point five inch pro
instead you'll be much more happy with
it now if you're not looking to spend
that much money the 2018 iPad for $329
is still the best deal for any iPad ever
it's good enough for almost everyone and
I still recommend it for anyone that
isn't looking to buy the new 2018 iPad
pro even better I've seen it on sale on
Amazon for as little as $250 brand new
you simply can't beat that value now
let's say you've been waiting a while
and you really want a new iPad but you
can't afford the new iPad pro well the
new iPad Mini actually isn't a bad deal
it's got everything the new air has but
with a smaller display for $100 less but
it's really meant to be in a market of
its own for those who want a smaller
display and more portability I oughta
still recommend going for the budget
2018 iPad unless you're buying the new
2018 iPad pro if you haven't seen our
one year review of the 2018 iPad click
the card above or click the end screen
button at the end of this video we've
already ordered both of the new 2019
iPad so we're gonna be doing in-depth
comparison videos very soon so if you're
not already subscribed make sure to do
that now thanks for watching and we'll
see you in the next video
[Music]